[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ عام
1730 وهذه العائله تعمل في صناعه السفن
التقليديه في ولايه الصور في سلطنه عمان
حيث تتوارث الاجيال هذه المهنه التي تشتهر
بها السلطنه لا سيما في المناطق الساحليه
[موسيقى]
مهنه هذه ورثناها احنا ابن عنجد
تقريبا احنا نكون اخر جيل ماسكين المهني
ولايه صور طبعا
باقي المناطق ما عاد فيها شيء خلاص
المصانع اول كانت اكثر من نصنع الحين اخر
مصنع في سلطنه عمان يمكن في الخليج اخر
مصنع
صناعات خشبيه او يدويه
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في اكبر هيكل لسفينه تقليديه في
سلطنه عمان هذه السفينه بدا العمل عليها
بدايات عام 2020 ومن المتوقع ان يتم
الانتهاء منها في اواخر العام المقبل
تكلفه هذه السفينه حوالي مليون دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
اكبر سفينه لصناعه هنا في سوريا من اكبر
صفه طولها تقريبا
35 متر اللي هو يعادل تقريبا فوق 70 دراهم
فوق تقريبا من 50 الى 55 متر
نوعيه الاخشاب اللي موجوده فيهن السائق
اغلى انواع السائق او اغلى انواع
متوفره كانت من افريقيا
هذه المهنه تواجه الكثير من التحديات
ابرزها انتشار السفن المصنوعه من مواد
الحديثه مثل الفايبر جلاس بالاضافه الى
عزوف الشباب العماني عن هذه الصناعه
والله شيء يعور القلب
من الحكومه المصريه
يضم هذا المصنع ورشه متخصصه بصناعه التحف
والمشغولات الخشبيه بالاضافه الى صاله
لعرض نماذج المصغره للسفن بكافه احجامها
وانواعها عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه
الصور العربيه